almost all american journalism is
controlled by a few massive corporations
news voice is a one-of-a-kind mobile app
that tracks the bias and corporate
interests that infuse the new stories we
consume every day
and it's completely free to use go to
newsvoice.com
pacman to download it dr anthony fauci
the top infectious disease doctor in the
country
who has been trying to run a coherent
coronavirus response and has been
fighting against the white house in
order to do it
is now begging and pleading with
americans to just listen to science
understand and accept what's going on
and
it's like reasoning with little kids
unfortunately in much of this country
here he is on msnbc
again having to explain that we have a
process for studying whether a drug
works
and that hydroxychloroquine doesn't work
follow the science if a study that's a
good
study comes out and shows efficacy
and safety for hydroxychloroquine or any
other drug that we do
if you do it in the right way you accept
the scientific data
but right now today the cumulative
scientific data that has been
put together and done over a number of
different studies
has shown no efficacy so when there's a
video out there
for a bunch of people spouting something
that isn't true
the only recourse you have is to be very
very clear
in presenting the scientific data that
essentially contradicts that
we have such an education crisis in this
country we have such a media literacy
problem in this country
that the top infectious disease doctor
is having to spend
a non-negligible amount of time just
explaining to people
we know how to study whether a drug
works and this one doesn't work you
shouldn't be taking it
and meanwhile trump is insisting it's
good congressman kovid louis gomert
says he's taking it now that he has
coronavirus
and this is how dr fauci is having to
spend his time
trump is still doing this in the last 48
hours trump said the following
times the it's recommendations of many
other peoples and people including
doctors
many doctors think it is extremely
successful
the hydroxychloroquine uh coupled with
the zinc
and perhaps the zithromycin
but many doctors think it's extremely
good
and some people don't some people i
think it's become very political
i happen to believe in it i would take
it as you know i took it for a 14-day
period
and i'm here right i'm here
they seem to now see everything as a
matter of opinion
it's all political your opinion is
hydroxychloroquine works
my opinion is that it doesn't these are
just differing opinions
the obvious hypocrisy here is that
it's the right that has come out waging
this battle
against what they call post-modernism
from the left they claim you know the
left
thinks words don't mean anything anymore
everything's just opinion there's no
more real truth
and yet they come out and then say
well our opinion is hydroxychloroquine
works when it comes to
what do the words man and woman mean the
right says the left
is playing too fast and loose with
definitions
and what things mean and yet here they
are
saying just a matter of opinion if
hydroxychloroquine works some people
believe it doesn't some people believe
it doesn't
as if science and medical studies don't
have anything to tell us about it
if their opinion is that a mask
could cause harm or as congressman covid
said a couple days ago
give you coronavirus then we have to say
well
their opinion is theirs and then we
might have scientific consensus but in
the end it's all just opinions
this is dangerous this is dangerous far
beyond the coronavirus situation that
we're dealing with right now
and this is also another problem i've
spoken of in the past
the idolizing of people over process
the idolizing of a cult of personality
when
it reigns supreme over understanding how
we come to know things and that's an
issue we've been talking about for years
in the united states we these are
estimates maybe 60 percent of the
population
will listen to science because they
understand how it works the other 40
is a combination of people who sort of
listen to science even though they don't
really know how it works but
it's sort of just like an argument from
authority for them and then an amalgam
of people who will follow their religion
or what they believe
their religion says or their cult leader
in this case
the cult leader can be a political
figure and this is unique to the right
imagine for a moment joe biden were
president coronavirus hits and joe biden
comes out and says
you know doctors say hydroxychloroquine
doesn't work but i think it does you
should take it
you're not going to see a lot of
leftists go and say joe biden said
hydroxy works
i'm going to take it even though doctors
say no this is a phenomena of the
american
right it does not exist in the left to
any kind of significant degree and this
is a cult-like
aspect of the right in the united states
and it's not just the type of thing we
talk about
in in academic settings this is causing
very real and concrete problems and if
you think it's bad now with this
hydroxychloroquine stuff and the mask
fiasco
just wait until a vaccine comes out
which maybe is
60 70 percent effective but 40
of the country may refuse the
coronavirus vaccine
as some studies expect will happen
40 45 of the country may opt
not to get a coronavirus vaccine once it
is available
horrifying absolutely horrifying make
sure you're following me on twitter
at dpakman and remember you can get the
daily audio podcast
every day you don't have to watch the
short youtube clips if you prefer a long
form
audio format when you're working out
when you're doing whatever it is that
you're doing gardening your zooks and
cukes maybe like me
grab the audio podcast on itunes
stitcher spotify pandora
whatever your favorite podcasting app is